Where were you four years ago on the night of January seventh
Honestly, Mr. Allen. I have no idea
How far back does this investigation of yours go? I'm not at liberty to discuss that with you
Also, um do you ever use public transit?
With like the subway, I mean imagine me in a wheelchair more like a bus
Is this really necessary I'm just being thorough
Fine I prefer lyft their wheelchair friendly
Honestly Mr. Allen how are my vehicle options are important what a date, I can hardly remember
I'm just trying to establish a timeline solve a mystery mysteries are for novelists and
Archeologists you were supposed to be ruling me out as a suspect
Instead it seems like you've got your guy. Oh, no this is just
procedure feels like persecution
Now, can I get back to you, or do I need to accompany you downtown?
No of course not
Um
Just email me sorry to bother you
Hey, what's going on? I think we know who he is
the name we're looking for is Clifford
Clifford DeVoe for once we actually have a chance here to get ahead of our enemy she sees that it's interfering with his work
you're not acting the way that you normally do. Look savitar and
Cadabra warned us about someone named DeVoe. This DeVoe guy could be behind everything Barry
is there a
Possibility that you were so determined to find the bad guy and get ahead of everything that you're seeing things exactly the way you want
To see them
No, it seems like he's getting a little crazed about this guy, so I think more than anything iris is just concerned
He's taking it too far. Oh my god. I don't understand why you don't see what's going on
He probably has cameras everywhere at the lab at CCPD. I mean he's always watching us when I left Earth
I went through some kind of wormhole
Quarrel calls that a disruption and it took me to the future
And I've been living on earth in the 31st century for the past seven years
Explains why is not allergic to lead anymore. L-Corp develops a cure about four hundred years from now
Everybody we got new flash
Let's break it down
And there is a new round of the flash ring giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
Leave a comment on the video. Uh that's a new winner at the end of this it yes
We finally have Legion of super-heroes on the DC TV show so I'll also explain how that's going to work because they are bringing
Brainiac 5 on to the shows so we'll finally have a legit version of Brainiac
But we finally have flash versus the thinker but the thing is is that he doesn't know anything about Mobius chair thinker
He only knows about this DeVoe person that he came to at his house, so he's a college professor
He just like slowly trying to piece a timeline together of
Where he was when the particle accelerator went off and then separately when the bus incident happened like he's trying to
Ascertain when he may have gotten powers like that's how he thinks this is happening, so he's not completely wrong
And we saw that other trailer where he's you know in the foreground with all these protesters in the background
And you see that flash effect where the Speed Force is nearby and all the liquids start to raise up so I've said it before
But I think the idea is is that he was actually at S.T.A.R. Labs when the original particle
Accelerator explosion went off and that's how he got hit with the Dark Matter
Wave but he was not in the wheelchair at the time so obviously the thinker is lying through his teeth
To bury like oh, you know, I can't take public transit
I can only take the lyft because of my wheelchair
So in the way that they're doing a lot of callbacks to season 1 this season
They're also calling back to Harrison wells being the fake crippled riding around in the wheelchair
Just because he was using it to try and absorb more Speed Force so in those other scenes in the last trailer
We saw the thinking cap lying on the pavement, and he slowly puts it on, but that's the last we see of it
So there's just like a slow evolution of the thinker in flashbacks that we'll probably get maybe through his
Perspective because I think we're past the point where Barry would just willingly travel back into the past and worry about messing with things again
flashpoint style
Because that would really be the best way to search the crime scene like you go back into the past four years and run around
while the blast is
Going off and just see if he's in the crowd somewhere
You can already imagine the look on Jay Garrick's face if he were to do something like that
So that's why they're giving him a villain
That's more of a Sherlock Holmes situation like he actually has to use his ability as a CSI
And you've seen that in the first couple of episodes to where he starts rattling off a lot of text speak
But the really cool thing about this week's episode and then obviously the crossover is next week, but the stuff
That's happening after the crossover is that we're finally into the thinker storyline
We've got like a little bit of him in each episode
but this is where they really start going at each other and you can see it's slowly driving very crazy because
Nobody else believes him the actor that plays Jesse Martin though
Also talked about Joe trying to get one step ahead of the thinker and they've only shot up to like episode 12
I think I don't think they're past Episode twelve at this point so the good news is that?
Sometime in the next couple of episodes the rest of the team will believe Barry something will happen so they're not gonna push this too
Hard this situation where nobody believes Barry?
And he has no way to prove it that can wind up being really
Frustrating for audiences like when one character has all the information and the rest of his friends don't believe him
They've done that in previous seasons like when everybody's lying to each other
That's why they sort of blew past that with the killer frost storyline this season where she just like comes clean to them right away
So like you can be on the team she could do the killer frost stuff so the same thing is gonna happen
with the thinker storyline in the
Thing that people may have forgotten is that Barry still has all those symbols that he wrote when he came out of the Speed Force
It's basically a timeline of everything that's happened, or is going to happen
They just haven't mentioned it in the last couple of episodes
So the evidence to take down the thinker in out him and solve you know whatever big
Problem that the thinker is trying to use the flash for is in those symbols
But in order for them to figure that out
They have to decode more of the symbols
And then actually like have a couple of them here one of the things come to pass like when he says this house is bitching
Like they actually have to hear somebody say that hey, wait a minute that was Barry's symbols
Maybe we should see if there's something else in those so we'll start decoding them more
So if you think it's funny that they haven't referred to those symbols in a while
They probably going to bring those back relatively soon
And we haven't seen them decode any of those symbols within eyeshot of the samurai head
So it seems like the thinker does not know about all of these symbols that Barry wrote down yet
But I'm sure that eventually all that information will get out by the back half of the season
but they're just so so many questions when it comes to Mobius chair thinker and wheel chair thinker because he doesn't have any of the
symbols carved into his forehead
He's not wearing any tech gear and his actual house looks like a normal house
So I'm wondering what the thinking cap has to do with this
But in the comics the thinking cap is this really classic old thing that just enables him to control other technologies
So we'll see what the thinking cap of the TV show does but because we're getting ready for the big four night crossover there might
Be some more footage for that tonight, so if we get some new stuff, then I'll try to work that into the videos
We've gotten one new look at the reverse-flash of the crossover the Blitz and flash
But it's been really blurry
So I'm expecting the next couple of trailers that we get to actually show him a little bit more
But usually what happens with TV is that they take up to like the last couple of days to finish all of the CG
Score it and that like everything that they need to
Broadcast it so the biggest reason why they haven't shown you a lot of new reverse flash is because they're just not done with that
Post-production yet, but that should happen pretty quickly and the thing is is I'm also working on a new Justice League deleted scenes video
So that will be next but let me know in the comments. What's your theory about the difference between?
Mobius chair thinker and wheel chair thinker like what is the connection because very clearly it's the same person
It's not like he has a twin brother. Who's this version of the thinker and he's this other version
It's got to be one person so there has to be some way for him to be both of these people
But I have a feeling that his wheelchair
Condition has something to do with what he was doing with the thinking cap in these flashbacks
The whole thing with the Legion of super-heroes if you haven't been watching Supergirl is that they just found a ship in the harbor
That's been there for 12,000 years. They have all these mystery pods. They've only opened Saturn girls
She's just one of the core members of the Legion of super-heroes
So this is the ma Nell roster brainiacs symbol is in the background here, so very clearly they're gonna
Thaw him out pretty soon, but all of these symbols represent the different members
But I'll post that Justice League deleted scenes video in the next couple of hours before
The flash episode then I'll post my flash episode video, so we'll say congratulations to the latest flash ring giveaway winner Samuel Thomas 101
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
There'll be a new round when I post that Justice League video in a little while you can click here for the big
Crossover trailer and you can click here for all my Justice League Easter eggs. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight